oh dude hashtag free britney
hashtag brittany freeman hashtag foreign
have you seen the you haven't the
britney spears
it's a i'd say documentary it's a one
part documentary it
started on fx it's on hulu if you
haven't seen it it's not really a
spoiler because we kind of know what's
going on in her life
so it's in i saw a preview for it i'm
like i need something to watch i'll
record that i gotta quit watching people
dying i'm gonna watch britney spears
career's diamond whatever
i record it dude that [ __ ]
was insane insane insane insane the way
the media treated britney spears was
[ __ ] up [ __ ] i told you guys last
night they came over the super bowl
party hashtag good friends hashtag bad
friend
and when you guys came over that's like
free brittany
for real free for real i'll protest with
you guys yeah let's do it
when you watch that how bad do you feel
i kept standing up and getting mad
getting mad yes i kept going what the
because dude
her father controls everything
everything if he wasn't in her life she
has
no sound even in her he was not part of
her come up at all
she goes crazy quote-unquote crazy
after she loses her children they won't
let her see her children when she shaved
her head and all that [ __ ]
it was because she couldn't see her kids
she was going [ __ ] nuts
dude you take my kids on top of
paparazzi
yeah oh my god the paparazzi was so
[ __ ] up
is that legal well now they've changed
the rules a little bit but kind of
because they were like all up in her
[ __ ] face but how [ __ ] up was it
how [ __ ] up was it when she was uh
doing interviews they're like uh
have you had sex with justin timberlake
yeah they could never do that now
how about they have that one guy on
there who uh he did a bunch of
documentaries
uh and it was anderson cooper and
they're like this just in britney spears
goes crazy and then he goes
i can idea how would you just leave her
michael moore goes
how about you just leave her alone why
why you guys like just leave her alone
why is everyone bugging and then cnn
scooper's like oh they seize up he's
like i got an idea how would you [ __ ]
leave her alone man yeah
that was my thing like leave her alone
yeah so like they they forced her
to pretty much you know react the way
she reacted think about it like if you
like there was like 12 just 12
characters like in her face in her
face all the time
she she went to the gas station to go to
the restroom she was coming out the
restroom
they they hounded her at the at the
[ __ ] uh
the door she was walking out of the
restroom and then they have an attorney
on there and they're
asking about you know uh basically contr
power control like she signed over and
her dad
has full power of her career finance
yeah real estate everything
and the attorney was like oh i went to
visit her just to see like mentally
where she's at
she's like she's aware of what her
father
represents the power that he has and he
goes just ask her a few questions
right away he's like oh no she doesn't
need this yeah like she he shouldn't
have this control over oh
so they even went to court with it and
they still they still grant her access
here's a crazy piece of [ __ ] so when
they go to court she's paying for her
her lawyers
and her and his are you serious and then
the person who was handling all her [ __ ]
goes i need a raise
and like whoa this isn't how it is
trying to get around
a business yes when it's supposed to be
a conservatorship that takes care of her
because the conservatorship is usually
in put in place because a person can't
take care of themselves
and so obviously she could uh the
uh court says that she mentally was
unable to take care of herself and she
had so much money that she would have
been taken advantage of so they put her
father in place in charge of
her as a person and her finances and
what she's saying is i
i don't want my father do it he's a bad
guy let a bank do it if you're worried
about that she goes i think i'm fine but
if you
if you're really really worried about
that let a bank do it not my father it
is different intentions
yeah yeah it's not strange how much was
she worth
a lot she's worth a ton and then now she
goes i'm not going to perform until you
yeah she won't put yeah
she won't do anything she has all these
offers like she's like i'm not going to
work until he doesn't have power
yeah because he's getting her money
she's getting her when she was like
doing the
american idol stuff because like she was
was
where she was the residency in vegas you
got the rest remember
vegas yeah then how about that one he's
getting her dad put together she's going
to do like
a ton of shows in vegas and she's
supposed to perform but she can't yeah
her dad put that together like yo we
need to make money do you watch that
you're like
help her out man yeah it's it's insane
and then you look and then you hashtag
free brittany hashtag please free
brittany
and then you uh hashtag baby one more
time but then you
hit me with your best shot but uh that's
not hurt
to say wait wait wait wait wait you're
you're dude you watch it and it's
it's so fun and then her her social
media she's literally crying for help
she she's literally like she's giving
all these signs like i need help man
even when she was on that horse yeah
everything anything she
when she falls on shows media because
her dad's so [ __ ] old don't know how
it works yeah
that's her asking for help from the
from the outside even better line was
like saying like
what does that say can i say i think
federline is like backing her up too
everyone is yeah her brother how about
her how about when they interview her
brother
he was like all the strong-minded women
and they got the interviewer was like
well that's a good thing right he's like
just certain extent he sounded bro he
sounded
he sounded [ __ ] whack this is crazy
this is crazy what is that this is our
instagram where's the crowd no i don't
know what that i'm talking about
no this is her just bored as [ __ ] but uh
go back and get out of here chin
go to the one where she looks crazy the
media
well that far left one with the video
the
another big black guy big another big
eye moment
you want to go to the black one yeah
sure let me see the body let's do it
a lot of you guys have been writing in
and you want to know what my main goals
are for 20 21
number one is to meditate more number
two is to take a cooking class
number three is to do a pilates class
and actually follow through with the
class
and number four is i've got to try this
ice cream diet
okay so i heard a lot of you guys see it
signs right there so when she walked
back and forth
she's pacing you know and she's reading
off something he's reading exactly we
took that nice acting class
i'll say this though after watching some
of the [ __ ] i'll say this hashtag free
brittany or choreography
brittany but also like there's something
off right
it's like you get a weird vibe when
you're watching this stuff and as much
as
when you watch that the documentary
obviously has a narrative to make us
feel this way which we get
and she should have control of her [ __ ]
if she's going to spend all her money
and give it to bad people
she's a grown adult she can do that it
happens to a ton of celebrities
but we don't know the facts so for a
court to go now the dad still should
control it it make and this is a court
that's supposed to be not you know
unbiased
we don't know exactly what's going on
she might be bat [ __ ]
crazy we're all free britney but she's
like she's like [ __ ] that free me you're
like whoa
but also at the same time you gotta look
at the way she came up
like i mean those early interviews with
her like
the way the way the public in the media
trader was insane
justin broke up you know people are
harassing justin like you owe her an
apology he's like [ __ ]
what yeah he's like and they said you
kind of like made the she
remember video based off of like
yesterday great song i remember that's
a great song she did she now you get
paid for documentaries who get paid
for that uh uh no i don't think
i don't think she she didn't participate
in it there's like people make money off
of documentaries but i don't think you
can pay
people to be in it no no no no no i'm
saying who yeah that's a good question i
don't know
wait what is wait what is your question
he's saying like did britney spears make
money off that doc i don't think so he's
not associated with it
like like oj dogs like the oj docks and
stuff he doesn't get paid off that
like the richard ramirez docks or
charles manson they don't get paid off
that but
certain ones i think if they're in it so
they said they reached out for brittany
to be in it and they
they never heard back and they think
that she never they never never got to
her
okay because so so you and stevie argued
because yes
my girl my girl's like you should do
something about this talk bring light
tonight and show them like
i'm just i hear you
i hear you i'm i'm not oprah you know
and my
however many people see this i get it
what's your girl saying
hashtag free britney but also it's kind
of like this tiger king like the
like joe exotic we're like we gotta get
him out
yeah yeah kind of but also he
really did hire someone to kill this
other person yeah he kind of should
probably do some time
i know it's a cool thing to do with
brandy too like you see these videos
you're like
hashtag free brittany but also also
controller finances you know what
i mean but that's yeah i just think it's
tough because it is super because
the media the media paints a certain
page all the time with everything
whether it's online or media which
online is kind of so
is media now yeah they'll paint a
narrative and you can really
run with it a certain way you know dude
when i was listening to like when
when they were interviewing like the
that pop those paparazzi dudes
i wanted to fight themselves i'm like
bro y'all
did this to a person like it's it was
like torture
the way they had these cameras up in her
face but it
happens a lot so they basically killed
princess diana too yeah that was good i
was gonna bring that up
another one for you and i just listened
to this uh podcast forget the name of it
shout out to whoever did it
uh on the brittany murphy one you
remember brittany murphy yeah
well so that one's interesting too
because the paparazzi kind of [ __ ] on
her
and like paint her in a bad light so she
couldn't get a job and then that
perez hilton was kind of a piece of [ __ ]
he was doing an interview and they said
uh who do you think's gonna like be the
next like marilyn monroe or something
like that and he goes
i i wouldn't be surprised if britney
murphy dies the next three months
she died in like three months so it's
just like this toxic
such a great actress by the way i love
you she was great i loved her
what's it heard she heard ashley kutcher
just married just me
great movie anyways
so stevie was like yeah there's some
reason because when the court of law was
like
yeah but the dad still should run some
of it and we'll bring in the bank so now
the bank is involved debate yeah
and the dad still do still involved but
when i hear that and you're talking
about high-powered lawyers that are
really looking at the case
and you have she's getting evaluated
like her mental capacity
there's something going on there man see
i think it's weird that she
is technically unfit mentally to take
care of herself but somehow she's fit
enough to perform constantly and bring
in all that i know and they make that
money
that's where like it doesn't make sense
to me and all of
like her mentality is insane oh yeah
even the dancers are like she's a beast
yeah they're like
everything she has like a specific eye
for what she wants but she doesn't want
i told my girl i went man you know for
what
you know hopefully not but if someone
took my kids from me like say me my girl
got divorced
somehow she had a case where you take my
kids from me dude i'd be going
[ __ ] nuts too man crazy and that's a
mom a mama bird
no of course she goes [ __ ] nuts yeah
they got cameras on her face
yeah like when she tried to go to k
fed's house to try to see her kids
and he wouldn't let her he wouldn't let
her and that's when they caught that
famous photo of her
uh umbrella yeah with the umbrella
the paparazzi dude was like yeah like
you know like
he was saying like oh we need each other
meaning like he's like she needs us as
much we need her like yeah
i know you're back at it you're a bad
person bad [ __ ] person and he tried
painting him so he's like you know i
always ask if she's doing all right like
get the [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] out of here you didn't you didn't
give a [ __ ] no pop pop they don't pop no
one gives scum of the earth man
no so can so they can't they can't do
that anymore there's some i don't know
what
what are the rules with paparazzi now
jen you have a computer in front of you
[Laughter]
let's see across the pond and the
continent in california probably are
legally prohibited from trespassing on
private properties in telephoto lenses
to survey private property
pursuing targets and cars however many
criticize the laws having little in the
way of
teeth to back up its threats of
liability
and you know some celebrities so let's
say so wait let's say you get super
famous and you're out to uh dinner with
your girl
you know paparazzi snaps a picture of
chappelle lacy and then it's a good
picture you look great in it
and then you post on your instagram
celebrities getting sued
by the paparazzi and winning going well
that's my
that's my work you owe me money well if
he tags him it doesn't matter
it's like dude that's my work it's like
yeah but it's me and i didn't give you
access
i didn't tell you to shoot that photo
are you weird
it's [ __ ] up another one that's weird
is when paparazzi follows around
uh child stars so [ __ ] up it's it's so
weird like how can a grown man or grown
woman
follow a child around l.a or wherever
they are to snap a photo dude when they
showed
me like walking out of a hotel with them
like four-year-old son son
and you you see him he's like imagine
that kid man
how do those paparazzi not have a
[ __ ] human heart
and just [ __ ] let these she's with
her kid let's let's let her chill man
you did not do you see where they got
the the paparazzi dudes were getting in
the fight
that was pretty funny or when they take
pictures of celebrities like when
they're on the beach and
who knows man maybe they're taking a
break from the crazy life in strict life
and
they're a little out of shape like go
look at the gut on
insert celebrity name yeah it's like
what the [ __ ] wrong with you guys
or they shoot a bad picture like kim k
like look at her dumpy ass like all
right dumbass
is
off of one photo of britney spears
that's insane what they were making they
used to sell
a photo of brittany they're hoping that
she looks disheveled and just out of it
they could sell a photo of her for a
million dollars back in the 2000s
that's why i saw crazy so the tabloids
ate that [ __ ] picture yeah that's how
they got their money
and then he and then the guy from i
think his people or us weekly
was like our marketing budget was 170
grand a week
and he was like we put a ton of it into
brittany he's like tens of million
dollars went to
them following brittany it's like [ __ ]
you man but they so they can't follow
people like that anymore right
there's some rule now if you're at home
they can't take pictures stuff like that
but if you're out and about they still
can
it's so disrespectful we see them at the
airport all the time
tmz waiting for him and that that's the
airlines the people on airlines the
the call up tmz like hey drake booked a
flight
to toronto from la so when they land
they know they're there
yeah it's like airport people releasing
like names who book flights that's how
they find out
so they get paid for that they're like
give me a tip there's like this weird
thing that uh
because uh adam sandler had stayed at
the hotel that i worked at
him and him and like his whole squad and
um
there was like a line of just people out
there i'm like how the [ __ ] did they
know that the hotel there's like
there's a yeah there's this thing that
basically this like kind of forum or
website or something
that could basically you could basically
follow where uh like a person like
that's on tour
yeah a celebrity that's like on tour or
something and find out like all these
things
about them it's kind of funny book
airbnb son you can't [ __ ] traffic
it's it's crazy yeah it's super crazy i
feel bad like because yeah we would get
like in the hotel i worked at we would
get like
all the the basketball teams and like
football teams and [ __ ]
and so people knew when they were coming
in and knew like
everything they knew everything i'm like
how the [ __ ] it's gonna be like
line and i i can't imagine like what
britney deals with like that's insane
oh dude and the kids and like you'd go
nuts
you'd go [ __ ] nuts you're the kids i
remember brock lesnar
was uh telling a story where he had his
kid and his armless one brock was like
the biggest thing in the world i was
fighting the ufc he was getting ready to
fight i think cain velazquez was shane
carwin
one of his big fights and he walked out
of like a gas station restaurant and had
his daughter in his hands
and the paparazzi was so frantic they
grabbed him while his daughter was his
hands the name was dropped his daughter
dude he was like oh i will rip your face
off
if you touch me again i will rip your
[ __ ] faces off and they're like okay
we have that we have that video i would
love to think kind of what did kanye
didn't kanye
[ __ ] up one of their cameras yeah yeah
he like tossed the camera but you can
see why they do
man like it's insane it's not
damn hashtag free britney hashtag but
also
let's let's get her help yeah yeah
you're here and getting a better help
i gotta watch i just it's just what it
is
why would you treat a person like that
yeah it makes you so she's so
talented and like we're missing out on
britney because she's just getting older
she could be touring she could do
residency in vegas
but because you're doing this thing
where her dad has all the power you're
not going to see her perform
when the last time she performed it's
been a minute 2000 and what
i don't give her some she performed at
an award show recently well not recently
but the probably
she um but she got a resurgence too
what was sad was those interviews with
of her as a teen three years ago or two
and a half years
they would like ask her about her tits
yeah they're asking about like oh yeah
everyone's talking about you
and your underwear and your breasts and
she's like i'm just here to talk about
my music like what
yeah she had a titties out no they just
they were just like no
she just dressed normal she was just and
then and then these would be these be
like live interviews and then like big
name like
anchors and analysts would be like oh
well
you know i don't like britney or like i
forget who was not diana sawyer one of
them was like oh
um i hate what she represents for women
i would shoot her if i could
the governor of maryland yeah oh yeah
the governor [ __ ] she's like the
weirdest [ __ ] yeah
she was you britney shoot yeah like
that's and they told brandon that she's
like
that's terrible a woman or a man said
woman woman and like she
bro a lot of these interviews like well
at least the interviews they were
showing on the dock like
you would just see her break down and be
so sad what's the end goal for that like
i don't know just
you want to see what everyone likes to
watch a star just fall yeah
because they're not hate themselves yeah
because they've never done [ __ ] with
their lives they like to see that oh
yeah it's [ __ ] terrible man what the
what the mayor of maryland look like
anyway the governor now she said
[ __ ] she looks like [ __ ] [ __ ]
really if i had an opportunity to shoot
britney spears i think i would damn
um and then spears record label jive
responds it's unfortunate
so did she uh come out and defend that
comment no
it's just a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] that lady
i wonder why they i wonder why they
never get like uh
yeah you see like and then you know
they never really got beyonce like this
you know they never like
she's from h you know and she and she i
mean she was a teen too
yeah but she was i think she was in a
group though it's different when she was
a teen she was in destiny's child
and then after she like mid-20s then she
became like they're saying too when
britney was coming up like
they just talked about her sexuality all
the time yeah she's and then
it was during bowie bands so then no one
talked about it like no one talked about
justin timberlake or nothing like that
ever
no one really talked about any of those
guys they just [ __ ] on britney all the
time
yeah it was literally just so you watch
it like what the [ __ ] is wrong with
people man because now that i think
about it i'll go why her
yeah there was like she wasn't the only
one like christina aguilera was
jessica's
i read something about britney spears
when she was coming up
uh her record label thought that when
she was younger and she was singing
she's saying so much like christina
aguilera that they didn't want
to compete with christina so they made
her change the way she sung to that i
heard that same thing
too yeah and it damaged her vocal cords
in the long run
and so it like it's not even just a
conservatorship that [ __ ] her over
it's like a record label all these other
things oh man
so mismanaged and still blew the [ __ ] up
yeah
so mismanaged [ __ ] being that famous
she better never i would never want to
be that famous no me neither
how about that when i get off stage at
the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this wrote a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son